we're going to talk about a classic
problem in mathematics this problem is
400 years old
it's about sphere packing the question
is what is the best way to pack spheres
and by best I mean what is the densest
way of packing spheres and it's thought
that the best way of packing spheres is
74 point zero five percent so if you
were packing a container it would be 74
percent for now it's been thought that
is the best way of packing spheres for
four hundred years and it was finally
proven in the 1990s however the referees
when they looked through the proof
thought they were 99 percent certain
that the proof was right so that's kind
of slightly unsatisfying so then they
started a a 15-year project to really
make sure that this is correct and
they've rewritten the proof in a formal
mathematical language which allows a
computer to automatically check the
proof which was finally accepted in 2017
finally proving the conjecture about how
densely you can pack spheres but the
problem itself goes back to so Walter
Raleigh of all people so Otto Raleigh is
very famous in Britain but he's an
explorer he's the guy who put his coat
over a puddle so Elizabeth the first
could walk over a puddle he invented the
potato and other lies very famous in
Britain I know and he wanted to know the
best way of packing his cannonballs on
his ships so he asked his mathematician
because everyone should have a
mathematician a guy called Thomas
Harriot
so he started looking through the best
ones packing cannonballs so perhaps one
of the obvious ways of packing spheres
would be something like this which is a
pyramid shape well with our triangle
base so a tetrahedron he sees people
stacking oranges or something in the
supermarket that we one way of doing it
but another obvious way of packing
spheres would be a square base pyramid
let's try that let's try that instead
break this apart let's try and make a
square base pyramid juice a couple of
extras here we go now it's obvious where
to fill the next layer because we're
going to fill these dimples
here so let's do that so we can fill
these holes with our next layer of
Spears I'm gonna put that one there
let's put this one here let's put this
one here and if we're lucky we should be
able to crown this with our last one
like that so we get a square pyramid so
that's another way of doing it perhaps
another obvious one would be with a
hexagonal base so we'll get a look at
that too so let's try and make a
hexagonal base so I'm gonna have a
central one there let's make a hexagon
around the center and then for the next
layer we would fill in those obvious
dimples so that would be one there
perhaps one there perhaps let's do one
there and I could crown this off with
another one but what I wanted to show
you and this is what Thomas how it
noticed is that all those packings are
actually equivalent that all the same
and they all have the same density as
well which is going to be this seventy
four point zero five percent so you
might be able to see that the hexagonal
packing is the same as the tetrahedron
twine it's the same kind of a packing
layer-by-layer
that this is less obvious I wanted to
point out this is also the same as the
square base pyramid but it's tilted on
its side
look there can you see that square there
so that square would be the square base
of the square based pyramid but it's
just tilted on its side all these things
are absolutely equivalent they have the
same density which is seventy four point
zero five percent actually Thomas
Harriet's pal which is Johannes Kepler
who you may know so I did that this
would probably be the most dense packing
possible so this is now known as
Kepler's conjecture but this is the best
possible which is the seventy four point
zero five percent figure so let's have a
look where that figure comes from
incidentally this is one of the early
beginnings of how atoms work or how we
started to learn the structure of atoms
if these spheres where atoms then this
kind of packing is what you find in I
don't know aluminium or copper if these
were the atoms of copper or in crystals
like just table salt if you look at a
crystal like that
you get this kind of packing but let's
look at where that figure comes from so
here's a small square based pyramid now
this just repeats wherever if
just imagine that repeating forever that
would be the idea of packing what about
if we can cut this up into some sort of
unit that we can then just repeat then
if we work out the density of the unit
that does the whole thing okay let's do
that what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
slice up this pyramid into a box I'm
gonna cut a horizontal line across the
top layer I'm gonna cut a horizontal
line across the bottom layer so I've cut
them in half and now I'm going to cut
four vertical lines so now I've created
a box and that box if you repeat it will
give you the whole packing so now I want
to know the density of the spheres
inside that box
well that box contains exactly one
sphere we've got half a sphere from the
top and then from the bottom layer I'll
cut it in half and then I cut it in
quarters so I've got four eighths of a
sphere so altogether that would make one
complete sphere so what is the volume of
one sphere well there's a formula for
that so that is 4 PI over 3 well R cubed
but let's just say it has radius 1
because there's no reason why not so I'm
just going to say it's 4 PI over 3 so
that'd be the volume of the sphere now
the box that I've made well we've cut it
across and vertically and so on it would
have a base of 2 by 2 so it'd be an area
4 and then we times that by the height
with a bit of Pythagoras you can work
out that the height is root 2 so the box
would have a volume of or root 2 so now
to find out the density we're going to
divide the volume of the sphere by the
volume of the box so if we divide
through you might be able to see we're
going to get a cancel out here with
these fours the density is going to be
PI over 3 root 2 and that figure is
something like zero point seven four
zero four eight and so on and that is
where our 74 point zero five percent
figure comes from there's the density of
these obvious packings
and it might seem obvious that that
would be the best way of doing it I
think so
I think it's obviously the most dense
but proving it's the most dense that was
actually quite difficult so one of the
first people who tried to take on this
and see if they could prove that this
was the best was Gauss gauss one of our
great mathematicians his name comes up a
lot in these things and what he did show
was that this was the best packing the
most dense packing if the structure is
regular but he didn't show if it was
always the best so maybe there's an
irregular packing that would be better
than this that is possible so this was
still an open problem it actually became
a very famous problem it became one of
David Hilbert's problems which was a set
of problems for 20th century
mathematicians it was his 18th
eventually though it was proven in the
1990s by guy called Thomas Hales with
Samuel Ferguson and what they did is
they slightly changed the way we were
thinking about this so I'm going to try
and show you what they did I'm trying to
give you the gist of the idea would be a
bit hand waving but we're going to try
our best so imagine a sphere packing in
three-dimensional space it's going on
infinitely and imagine it's as full as
possible as well so there aren't gaps
that are big enough to fit any extra
spheres in so this is as full as
possible
now each sphere is defined by its center
so instead of a problem of packing
spheres you can think of it off the
problem of points in space so like a
network points in space each sphere had
a radius of one then these points would
have to be at least two units apart so
what they did is they started looking at
the local structure near a given sphere
I'll show you the sort of thing I mean
if we had say one of the hexagonal
packings let's do that let's say we have
this Center sphere here the local
structure to that would be these six
Spears going around the equator there
would be three spheres at the top and
three spheres below it so that would be
the local structure around that
hexagonal packing now they would give
the local structure a score now that's
just a number there's a technical
definition for that and they would give
it a number now if each local structure
has a score less than the hexagonal
packing score then they've proven the
conjecture so that means that the
hexagonal pack
would be the densest packing so now the
question was is there a local structure
that has a score greater than the
hexagonal packing is there a
counterexample so what they did is they
created a list of five thousand
potential counter examples eventually
they actually whittled that down a bit
to about 100 and then they just checked
them they just checked them one at a
time to see the score and if each one
has a score less than the hexagonal
packing you can dismiss it and
eventually they were able to dismiss all
of 100 of these potential counter
examples which means there are no
counter examples and that proves the
conjecture that means that the hexagonal
packing is indeed the densest packing
possible 74 point zero five percent and
it was a series of papers throughout the
90s and the theoretical stuff is
traditional mathematics and then when
they started checking through these
counter examples that was what was done
by computer and this is why they were
slightly unsure if the proof was 100%
correct because he can't check the
computers working really so that's why
they started this project this 15-year
project it turned out to be where they
wanted to formulize the proof so they
turned to their proof into this
extremely formal mathematical language
which was formal enough that a computer
can automatically check it I think
that's pretty efficient actually and
because I know people have tried to do
this experiment early so if you were
transporting grain or something that's
like a sphere and you just let it
loosely settle down I think you get
naturally something like 64% so clearly
if you make a structured packing like
this you're getting something much
better than that so the conjecture was
finally proven which means that seventy
four point zero five percent is the
densest packing of spheres including all
possible regular packings all possible
irregular packings and it has some
rather surprising applications as well
so it can be applied to if you're
looking at the structures on atoms
surprisingly I think it can also be used
in how we transmit messages around
on the Internet today I can't see any
link there this is the first of a sphere
trilogy with dr. Grimes
see the video description for more
information about the others and our
thanks to brilliant for supporting the
series brilliant is a website you should
know them by now they're full of great
courses and quizzes and all sorts of
puzzles you can do to help kind of well
make you smarter get you thinking about
things differently
there's mathematics science computer
science and all this content is just so
beautifully designed it's really elegant
it's really fun to do as well if you'd
like to have a look at them and I
recommend you have a look at them
there's lots of stuff for free on the
site go to brilliant org slash
numberphile if you use the slash
numberphile they'll know you came from
here but you'll also get 20% off if you
decide to sign up for their premium
service which unlocks all the goodies
you could want check them out
brilliant org slash numberphile now
thanks to them for supporting this
series
[Music]